Eh bien bonjour les amis ! Bienvenue dans cette deuxième video !
AU CANADA !
Cette fois on est plus du tout à Montréal,
On est à Outaouais. Clément arrive en marchant vers moi, qu'est-ce qui se passe Clément ?
Clément:je suis pas sûr que le micro...
mais les gens m'entendent bien t'en fait pas
EH JE SAIS FAIRE MON MÉTIER CLÉMENT!
Qu'est ce qu'il y a marqué ici ?Vous savez tous lire
Il y a marqué parc OMÉGA
C'est 800 hectares d'habitat naturel
On va se balader au milieu des animaux en voiture
On va dormir dans un tipi
*rire* Un truc traditionnel c'est fou
j'ai toujours voulut faire ça
Je vous propose qu'on y aille tout de suite, Parc OMEGA, c'est parti, jour 2 au Canada!
SQUEZZIE:Bonjour messieurs!
André:Bonjour!
SQUEZZIE:Comment ça va?
André:Ca va bien Lucas?
SQUEZZIE:Ouais! Toi tu t'appelle comment?
André:André!
SQUEZZIE:André! Enchanté André!
Serge:Bonjour!Ça va bien?
SQUEZZIE:Bonjour!
Serge:Serge!
SQUEZZIE:Serge!Enchanté!
Vous allez être nos guide,
Serge: Oui, absolument
SQUEZZIE: Sans vous,
Içi notre espérance de vie,
Serge: oui oui oui
SQUEZZIE: est de deux minutes apparament.
Dites-nous qui vous êtes! On veut tout savoir
Serge: Alors Serge *Juicier* (?)
J'suis directeur technique et porte-parole du parc Omega
André: Et moi je suis André Saint-Georges (Clap) je suis agent de communication
chez tourisme Otaouais.
SQUEZZIE: Donc tu fréquente
un peu moins les animaux.
André: Boh j'vais faire mon tour!
(Rire)
Bon de toute façon a Otaouais yen a plein d'animaux donc heu..
SQUEZZIE: Waa ça a l'air d'être une très très belle région!
Vous nous avez prévus un petit programme apparemment
André: Oui, oui ouioui.
SQUEZZIE: Ques qu'on va faire ce soir?
Serge: Le parc Omega c'est la découverte de la nature
Canadienne, de sa faune, de son histoire,
SQUEZZIE: Ouais.
Serge: Et de l'esprit des onze (11) premières nations du Quebec
Alors ce soir
On va faire un face a face avec une meute
de loup!
SQUEZZIE: Je les aimes déjà!
Alors est-ce qu'on peut dire que Serge ressemble à Chris Pratt,
dans Jurassic World?
*Ressemblance 2%*
(Clap) Montons dans cette voiture et voyons des animaux c'est partis!
On est chaud on est chaud comme la braise!
SQUEZZIE: Hop!
Salut mon pote!
Serge: Un contact privilégié avec la faune Canadienne!
SQUEZZIE: Waaa!
C'est super massif quoi!
Le premier animal que je nourris du parc! Un wapiti!
Animal typique Canadiens!
Serge: J'vais essayer de trouver un mâle
Avec les grands panaches!
SQUEZZIE: Au revoir la femelle!
(Inserez musique triste)
SQUEZZIE: Elle était tellement triste!
T'en veux ou pas mon gars? C'est une super belle carotte!
Serge: A coté de toi!
SQUEZZIE: OH!
Allez hop! Il a compris!
(rire collectif)
(Voix que je comprends pas) Oh!
Serge: Une dinde sauvage.
SQUEZZIE: Oh! Tu veux une carotte?
(rire) Le mec qui a pas compris la nature!
Maintenant c'est le premier mâle qu'on voit! Salut mon grand
Tiens regarde une carotte! Tiens tiens tiens tiens.
Toi tu en a besoin toi mon gars! Y pè.. ça pèse combien un watipi?
Serge: Quatre-cent cinquante (450) kilos
SQUEZZIE: Ah faut pas l'enerver du tout!
On est tombé sur un ours!
Tout va bien!
Serge: Fait un sourire! (Paroles que je ne comprends pas)
SQUEZZIE: Oh!
On va tenter de faire se lever un ours!
ça va être flippant!
ALLEZ VIENS ALLEZ HOP!
Ok il s'en bat les cou*lles...
ALLEZ HOP!
Serge: ALLEZ HOP!
Ohhh un petit effort encore!
SQUEZZIE: Il s’appuie sur l'truc  il a la flemme de se lever c'est dingue!
Serge: ALLEZ HOP!
Oh bein il y arrive!
SQUEZZIE: Ouiiiiiiiii
Serge: Tu vois la? Tu l'as eu! Récompense!
SQUEZZIE: Ettt voilà mon grand!
SQUEZZIE: Oh bah oh putain j'te l'ai mis dessus excuse moi!
(rires) Merde!
Bon a part avoir vus tout ces animaux et leur avoir donné des carottes
On change de véhicule et on passe sur un...
ET REGARDE LE C'EST CHRIS PRATT!!
(rire)
Serge: Venez avec moi!
SQUEZZIE: Tu nous ammène ou? Au tipi là?
Serge: Alors la on va au tipi!
SQUEZZIE: Et on peut y aller seulement avec ce véhicule?
Serge: Absolument!
SQUEZZIE: Ohlala!
J'ai l'impression d'être a Jurassic Parc mais j'te jure!
SQUEZZIE: On est arrivé au tipi. On va dormir la dedans
C'est fou! On va dormir dans un vrai tipi mec!
On va s'faire un feu on va boire des bières!
On va faire un bon délire entre amis! Avec Serge qui va nous raconter plein de belles histoires!
C'est sur! Avant d'aller voir les loups! (rire)
T'as dompté un T-Rex un fois j'crois Serge?
Serge: Absolument!
Deux!
(rires)
Alors...
Vous êtes prêts?
SQUEZZIE: On est prêts a voir!
Serge: Allez!
SQUEZZIE: Clément honneur a toi vas y!
Prends place Clément!
Eh on va pouvoir se pécho la dedans Clément regarde ça! (rire)
Waaaaaa
ça sent bon! ça sent le bois de ouf!
Mec t'as vu comme c'est haut? Tu te sent bien!
Ya même des ours! Sur les couvertures!
On vit le délire à 100%!
Petites serviettes (Lennyface) Tu va te doucher où? Dans la rivière?
Tu te douche où? Pourquoi tu fais ça?
A tu veux.. A PUTAIN IL M'PECHO LE CON!
Sa sent super bon!
Clément: ça sent le bois.
SQUEZZIE: Vous sentez vous?
C'est fou!
Clément: Oh Putai..
(rires)
SQUEZZIE: Ok on s'enfonce actuellement dans les bois pour rencontrer les loups!
Allez let's go! On te suit
C'est toi le boss.
Amène toi!
Serge: Alors.. Les loups!
SQUEZZIE: Ils sont juste a coté! Et lui c'est le mâle Alpha,
Qui est juste ici, c'est le chef de la meute!
Les amis Serge nous invite à nourrir les loups!
On va nourrir des loups mec c'est jsute fou!
Serge: Maintenant je te donne un morceau de viande.
Serge et SQUEZZIE: Ouais il l'as eu!
SQUEZZIE: C'est bon!
Serge: Voilà!
SQUEZZIE: Waaaa!
A ouais ils ont.. Nous quand on fit ça avec des Haribo ça marche jamais quoi,
Eux ils ont clairement ça dans le sang!
Allez allez!
Serge: Voilà!
SQUEZZIE: Waaaa
C'est fou j'adopte! C'est partis je repars avec! Allez hop j'arrive!
Serge viens de m'expliquer,
Que c'est que le mâle Alpha qui.. Qui hurle en premier,
Et ensuite les autres vont le suivre.
Mais si lui il hurle pas, les autres vont pas pouvoir hurler
Et en fait quand ya une meute qui est petite,
Par exemple la c'est une meute de treize (13), mais quand ils sont par exemple six (6),
Et bein le mâle Alpha va pas trop hurler, il va pas trop faire le malin,
Parce que les meutes sont capables de compter combien ya de loups dans l'autre meute,
Pour doser la puissance d'une meute quoi.
Serge: Absolument!
SQUEZZIE: C'est assez fou!
Et du coup la vus qu'ils sont treize (13), ils hurlent souvent vu qu'ils sont assez nombreux
Serge: A ouais ouais ils hurlent a peu près tout les jours
SQUEZZIE: Donc du coup cette nuit,
On risque de se reveiller heu... parce qu'ils crient, ils vont hurler quoi!
ça va être fou! Des vrais loups! Ce sera pas Serge comme la!
Ce sera vraiment des loups qui crient!
Serge: Exactement!
(rire)
SQUEZZIE: Ou alors pt'être on va entendre un cris on sortira et on verras Serge comme ça devant le tipi!
"WOOO VENEZ AU PARC OMEGA WOOO"
(rires)
Serge, Milles mercis pour cette expérience de malade!
Serge: Bah c'est un grand plaisir de vous faire découvrir cette belle nature
SQUEZZIE: Behh le plaisir est partagé à 200%!
Merci je te fais un calin!
Serge: Avec.. Avec grand plaisir!
SQUEZZIE: T'es trop sympa!
Bonne nuit repose toi bien! Demain on veux que tu soit en forme! A demain!
Serge: A demain!
Ciao!
SQUEZZIE: Ciao! (rire)
Les amis je me fais réveiller par les cris de loups...
C'est fou!...
Ou alors c'est Serge... Je sais pas...
C'était puissant!...
Les amis on à dus quitter Serge, c'était triste hein..?
André: Ouais c'est triste.
SQUEZZIE: Ah c'est triste putain...
André: C't'un bon gars Serge
SQUEZZIE: Serge, je sais que tu regarde cette vidéo
Merci pour tout ce que tu nous a offert! C'était dingue mec!
Aujourd'hui, Deuxième jour en Outaouais Otaouais pardon excuse moi
André: Outaouais ouais.
SQUEZZIE: Outaouais, bien sur je connais, Outaouais!
On va faire du rafting. Toute la journée! Ca va être fou en plus il fait,
Hyper beau! On est juste devant la maison des gens qui vont nous emmener heu.
Faire du rafting. J'propose qu'on aille les rencontrer
André: Et sur le plus grand cours d'eau
du Quebec! Rien de moins
SQUEZZIE: Le plus grand cours d'eau du Quebec! C'est partis!
Putain on enchaine trop de trucs cool dans ce voyage c'est fou!
Rebonjour.! Je suis Jean Michel Alaise
Et je vais vous présenter Kevin et Philippe !
(rire) Comment ça va les gars?
Kevin: Salut!ça va?
SQUEZZIE: Ques qu'on va faire aujourd'hui?
On va faire du rafting on m'as dis!
C'est pour ça que ya un rafting sur ton T-shirt
Philippe: (Nom de la boite)
SQUEZZIE: C'est raccord!
On va aller dans une rivière grande!
Philippe: Beaucoup d'eau heuuuu eau chaude.
SQUEZZIE: Attend il essaie de nous séduire il a dit "eau chaude", sa se voit
Il sait qu'on est Français qu'on est frileux, il a précisé "Chaude"
ça va beaucoup remuer
Kévin: Ouais.
(Clap)
SQUEZZIE: C'est très bien on retourne a Montréal  c'est partis on y va! (rires)
Parce qu'on a quand même du signer un truc en disant que heu. Si on meurs c'est pas grave.
(rires) Ya vraiment marqué "Ok si tu meurs c'est pas grave on est pas responsables" et,
Tu sais ques qui est le plus flippant?  Anecdote! Le plus flippant c'est pas le  rafting,
C'est une Tic! On a appris que ya une tique (rires)
Qui peut, Ya une tique sur cinq (5) qui peut te filer une maladie
Et, si tu fais rien pendant soixante-douze (72) heures, genre si tu l'as pas vu quoi!
Et bein tu deviens invalide. Voilà. (rires)
Elle t'attaque direct le système neurologique
Avec Clément, on arrête pas de phaser, on partout oû on va on se dit
"mais mec, ça se trouve il y a une tique...ça se trouve il y a une tique..."
C'est terrible mec
Fais gaffe, il y a une tique à tes pieds
Clément : Oh putain
SQUEZZIE: Donc voilà. Il y n'y a pas trop de tiques sur la rivière?
Philippe: Non vous ne risquez rien
SQUEZZIE: Allons sur la rivière tout de suite! Allons nous en! (rires)
Ok, ok, ok, ok, attends, attends on se calme! (rires)
SQUEEZIE: On vient d'apprendre quelque chose d'incroyable, cette personne possède... un ANTI-TIQUES!
CETTE PERSONNE: UN ANTI-TIQUES!
WOOOOO
SQUEZZIE: Et alors la mon gars on va faire du raft comme jamais, ça va être fou!
Nous sommes arrivés au départ! Pour le rafting l'eau est juste derrière nous!
Clément a sa Go-Pro su la tête il va pouvoir me filmer
Moi j'vais vous mettre Ici ! Vous allez être comme ça!
Le bateau est la! Putain mec
Il est très très beauw
On nous a expliqué, ce qui fallait faire ce qui fallait pas faire
J'ai juste trop envie de voir Clément se faire ejecter du bateau je sais pas pourquoi
(rire) J'suis un connard!
C'est partie?
Nous sommes sur le bateau!
Ya du monde derrière
Qui va dégager de ce bateau en premier? Les paris sont lancés!
Philippe: Alors vous devriez avoir au moins une fesse sur le tube extérieur!
SQUEZZIE: Ah d'accord! A comme ça tu dégage, tu dégage bien comme ça aussi!
Philippe: Comme ça c'est plus confortable.
SQUEZZIE: C'est la position pour dégager mon gars! (rires)
C'est le moment de la première rapide!
On est parés?
(rire) ça fait déjà vingt (20)  minutes qu'on.. Qu'on rame.
Moi mes bibis ils asument plus du tout!
(Cris blupblupblup)
SQUEZZIE: Ahhhhhh! ça secoue bien!
OH C'EST LA DEUXIÈME! (plus de cris)
(Toujours plus de cris)
(Le dernier cris?)
SQUEZZIE: On l'as fait!
Philippe: Maintenant on va essayer de surfer sur la vague!
SQUEZZIE: Ok on va retourner dans les rapides et on va essayer de surfer cette fois
Regarde ça c'est fou! Ça remue beaucoup! ON Y VA!
Philippe: GO GO GO!
(Rest in peace SQUEZZIE
SQUEZZIE: Bon tout est dans la HAHA (rires)
Clément il est tout la-bas!
CLÉMENT!
Ça va Clément?
T'as kiffé? Mais mec tu m'es tombé dessus c'était hilarant!
(rires)
De tout ton poids tu as...
C'est fou!
Bon les amis gros kiff! Jean-Michel guide nous a proposé de faire euh. les rapides
A la nage! Sans bateau! On va revivre une noyade
Imminente, Une deuxième fois! (rire)
C'est très bien! Allez on y va!
Je me fais caca dessus!
On est tipars? C'est partis!
(A non. Un autre cris.)
Ok position aérodynamique!
(Toujours plus de cris)
(bloup)
Jean Michel Guide: Viens donc par ici! La c'pars ici!
(cris et rire sadique)
SQUEZZIE: Oh! Oh la bonne tête! de fou j'savais!
Les amis c'est la fin de cette journée, et de cette deuxième vidéo au Canada.
J'espère qu'elle vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hesitez pas a l'aimer comme d'habitude.
J'en ai marre de dire cette phrase putain. Faut que je change.
J'vais dire Tabarnak a la place maintenant (rire)
C'était une exellente seconde jounée
Bon vous devez être choqué parce que c'est d'un coup la nuit.
Alors que juste avant on était encore sur le bateau..! En vrai entre les deux ya eu un petit barbecue
Avec Philippe et Kevin! Notre guide et notre heu, sauveteur!
Heuu. Actuellement on est dans un chalet  ya même pas d'electricité!
On est vraiment en pleine nature c'est trop cool!
C'est ouf parce que c'est la première fois que rencontre des gens, comme Serge
et André heu. AU parc Oméga. Et vingt-Quatre (24) heures après
Bah j'dois déjà les quitter, pour aller en rencontrer d'autres. Et j'sais pas.
C'est bizarre! Serge il me manque de ouf! C'est fou! Il était tellement
Même André! Et même demain ils vont nous manquer
Kévin et Philippe! Une vraie aventure de ouf que je suis en train de vivre
Et heu. Bah voilà. On est, au deux tiers finalement il nous reste plus que deux jours sur six (6) a vivre!
Ca va être cool! J'espere que vous apprécierez la prochaine vidéo aussi!
Allez trève de plainsanterie il est vraiment tenmps de dormir.
Pour être en forme demain parce qu'on a encore deux grosse jounées qui nous attendent..!
Allez bonne nuit ciao!